we are inching closer and closer to the
nfl draft which of course being held
right here in our city that's right
we've been keeping track on all the
updates on the strip as we prepare to
host this massive event kevin martin is
live now to walk us through the draft
experience kevin
well thanks kirsten things are starting
to take shape down here on the strip as
we are just 10 days away from the nfl
draft kicking off and as you can see
behind me they are making some serious
progress on the draft theater which is
located behind the high roller and will
house the main stage also in this area
where we are standing now will be the
nfl draft experience which is an
interactive football theme park and will
be open all three days of the draft
these two locations as well as various
others located around the strip
including the red carpet and floating
stage in the bellagio fountains will be
must-see attractions for the hundreds of
thousands attendees
it's not a cookie cutter event we're not
just taking what we did in chicago
philadelphia new york and just placing
it in a new city we really want to take
on the life of where we are we want to
you know show
you know a sense of place and what
better way to do that than to have
you know the red carpet in the bellagio
fountains and to have our
massive theater right
by the high roller
and eric went on to say that vegas has
indeed set the bar high for future host
cities he said the pressure is on for
both kansas city and detroit where the
draft will be heading next reporting on
the strip kevin martin live local now